i've actually been to leonardo
dicaprio's like real home
let's serve up some news sunny side up
food and wine reports that a v-day
classic is back just in time sweetheart
conversation hearts and they've been out
of the candy game yes for years okay
these are so old school and they are
back and better than ever i love these
as a kid i know they've been making
tongues chalky since 1902.
and they're like flirty time capsules
through the years we've had groovy on
them even to fax me
hello hello and then this is so great
these are all love songs this year it's
so cute they have like a beyond like um
crazy love uh-huh yeah they're really
it's really clever like you know how
they how they do it oh there's a bunch
of different songs uh all of me oh john
legend song nuts sugar sugar at last oh
eddie james i love it
story really really really speaks to me
ross
so the new york post reports that this
garbage truck driver in ohio well
he saw something like moving in the
garbage he saw like a backpack actually
like shape-shifting and he went
and he picked it up and he unzipped it
and inside
was a abandoned puppy oh my gosh you're
trying to kill me drew i know yeah and
good luck she's um getting it she he
took her to the vet
she got treated and ultimately he said
you know what i think we found each
other and i'm gonna adopt her there is a
reason that man saw that bag move and
this is one of those stories that if
you're having a bad day and a story like
this pops up on your news feed it's for
a reason too because it makes you
remember there's so there's so much
goodness in the world i find out i found
out about it and it just overtook my
whole day it just gave me that hope the
look in both of their eyes
i just i really i really took this one
to heart i have to say
leo's former interior designer megan
weaver just revealed that his old malibu
beach house was titanic themed it was
decked out in titanic towels a titanic
poster she would wear the titanic robe
around and the designer was like wait a
minute all these titanic touches she
doesn't think they were put there by leo
but his proud mama irmalin
how cute is that okay see i think it's
so cute and if i was in like one of the
most the highest grossing films of all
time i would have it too i was in the
hobbit in seventh grade you guys
probably heard about it i was a
revelation and i which character did you
play the hobbit thank you very much and
if i could get like ross matthews as the
hobbit bathmat when i was in seventh
grade yeah uh i would have yeah yeah
yeah would you do you have anything in
your house like nothing anyway i will
say
nothing why not no it's all in boxes in
storage i don't need me
oh girl i would have me everywhere i
will say though that i've actually been
to leonardo dicaprio's like real home
and he is so not self-indulgent there is
no me me me his taste is impeccable his
art collections to die for and
um i think this was like the cutest
thing ever but he doesn't live like that
to my knowledge
michelle obama will star in waffle and
mochi it's a brand new kids cooking show
featuring dishes from around the world
it's very global and if michelle obama
wasn't sunshine enough check out her two
co-stars waffle and mochi they're the
cutest things i can't even handle it it
premieres march 16th thoughts i think
it's great i love muppets in any form
except for creepy ventriloquist dummies
but i love puppets and muppets i had
like a crush on jason siegel just
because he did those puppets yeah mm-hmm
i think he wrote the muppets movie and
the music i just i love them i think
they're so cute
a writer at instyle just came up with
this genius idea of how to do this she
was recently divorced so she went on
zola
which is a wedding registry
site and
she opened up a registry for one
and there were so many simple things
that she lost in that divorce whether it
be pots pans towels
and
let me tell you when you get a divorce
you do have to build your life back up
and as cute and quippy as this story
might seem this one really caught my
attention
i think this is awesome and you don't
even have to be married to go through
this you could have just lived with
someone and i
think this is revolutionary
and it's a great way to make a very
difficult situation celebratory
as well as help solve the problem
[Music]
i got this from my daughters and it's
the irish fairy worry plaque so you put
your hand on there
and if you can see it turns you can see
it's red
and then you keep it there and you kind
of let go of your worries and then
oh
and it's just a great way listen we
could all use a little imagination and
if you have to
grab a worry plaque put your hand on it
think something beautiful take a deep
breath and let those fairies take your
worries away well
that's one way
[Music]
you